un match à oublié pour l'AS morpa en
difficulté dans le championnat de D1 de
district les morpasiens n'ont pas réussi
à rebondir pour accrocher leur première
victoire de la saison ils se sont
largement inclinés à domicile contre
bayinoisi l'un des favoris à la montée
le score 4 à1 à la fin du
match début de match un petit peu
difficile on encasse de buts dans les 20
premières minutes je pense sur des
petites faut d'inattention ensuite voilà
on arrive à faire plus ou moins jeux
égal on a quelques
occasions par la suite avec les quel on
pourrait revenir dans le match assez
facilement je pense mais voilà on arrive
pas à les mettre au fond à les
concrétiser et derrière voilà défait en
championnat après ce résultat bayinoisi
est 3è et morpas s'enfonce au classement
les morpasiens sont derniers avec un
bilan de trois défaites en TR matchs
avec 15 buts encaissés les dirigeants
semblent tout de même confiants malgré
ce début de saison compliqué du club
c'est une phase de reconstruction donc
ça va se construire tranquillement il va
y avoir un esprit d'équipe qui va venir
et puis ça ça se passera mieux pour la
la suite du
conf avir ce premier résultat accrocher
ce premier résultatil domicile
l'extérieur c'est très important je
pense que sur la suite ça
continuera surprise la de la saison la
prochaine journée de de district est
prramm le diche 22 octobreend sur la
pelouse
d'isev les
Mau